I
I really enjoy to a war war hammer these
are two franchises that I've wanted to
to meet for years and they both have
unique aspects that kind of that they
were there were meant to be together
you've got the grand battles of fantasy
of Warhammer and also the large
campaigns giant maps and massive amounts
of infantry from total war and they both
work together wonderfully in a way that
I've been hoping for since I've been
about 14 total war war hammer was pretty
cool I struggled with some areas there
was less of a tutorial than in earlier
total war game so there was quite a bit
of assumed knowledge at least in the
state that is currently in right now I
know they're still working on some
things which is contributed to the delay
things like balancing but I found early
on it was easy to forget that you had a
settlement way back where that needed to
be defended each race plays very
differently the humans are kind of like
your most classical total war factions
with the addition of magic and Griffin's
whereas dwarves are very defensive and
focus on artillery and even have a book
of grudges where they take note of any
time you've stepped against them and
then there's things like green skins who
have to constantly fight about their
entire campaign or they just evolved
into bickering and killing themselves I
think the fantasy definitely added to
the experience not that I didn't like
the total war settings where it was just
like a bunch of dudes who were different
forms of military but this just felt
very like a movie esque it felt really
cool if I like you're in the middle of a
big fantasy warfare setting and I don't
think I can think of any other games
that really give you that large-scale
real-time combat feel with fantasy
creatures what are most interesting
additions to tell a war warhammer our
story based battles and he requests so
sometimes battles will pop up in the
campaign map that have kind of a
scenario attached to them so you can
march your army whatever it consists of
to that point and take place in a little
bow that will give you a bonus and we'll
have a little bit of lore attached to it
whereas he requests are how you develop
your legendary Lords so in the case of
the vampire counts manfred von Kahr
stein he will have a set of quests and
if you accomplish said quest whether
it's to take a town or sacks
we're or killer warboss you will unlock
new mounts new weapons new war gear and
each piece of war gear gives a bonus
whether it's a legendary aura or attack
spells anything like that and that is
new to warhammer total war especially in
the way it gives you new items and you
know eventually a flying dragon one of
the things I found to be a little
challenging was the vampire faction that
we were playing as most of the time it
doesn't have any ranged units and that's
not something that any total war games
have had before with any of their
factions and it is extremely challenging
going up against especially the humans
who have so many ranged units one of the
skirmish battles that we got to play
which was removed from the campaign was
us being the humans against a bunch of
vampires and it was pretty easy to wipe
them out with ranged units so being on
the other side of that was really tricky
and I think it's going to just take
experience with the faction and figuring
out where the advantages are against the
other sides and that's something the
total war developers are working with to
try and rebalance and I'm sure we'll
have to work with to figure out so it
should get better one thing I was a
little bit disappointed in as someone
who came from a background of painting
the Warhammer figures and collecting
them I always went off color scheme when
I was painting my little figures and
total war warhammer isn't really giving
you much in the way of customisation
when it comes to your entire army I for
one was thinking that I would create a
green-skinned army and dress all my orks
in pink vests and send them all into
battle but unfortunately at the moment
we can't quite make the pink orcs this
does feel really similar to other total
war games I think what makes it
different is if you really pay attention
to the battle and you just look at your
creatures and you're like a massive
swarms of bats as I said or your heroes
are actually huge werewolves and things
like that that is so different it's like
a completely familiar total war format
with this other injection of a really
cool fantasy theme the other thing works
quite well from what I've seen so far I
think the Warhammer franchise in the
Warhammer law adds a lot to total war
previously took war felt like you were
kind of creating your own game and your
own story now with the addition of years
of law from the Warhammer franchise
we're getting to know characters we get
to know a world beyond what we can just
see on a map it's not just a historical
version of our wide world so that
already adds a lot to the world a total
war and then like I said you have things
like goblins orcs dragons vampire bats
as well as a slew of magic so really
total war has been begging to the
fantasy element to be injected into it
for years and I have to say it's pretty
exciting and what they have made with
these two giant franchises finally
meeting is pretty great so far
you